how old are all of you how old are you
i'm late twenties actually you don't
wanna say not an exact date
twenty-eight what's wrong with being
twenty-eight how old are you i'm
twenty-eight oh okay they're like i
wanna change it
one of the hardest parts of dating is
guessing someone's intentions are they
truly interested in you or are they
looking out for themselves
how do you know when you're being played
we created a game show to find out one
bachelor looking for love will meet five
potential matches
i'm in it for love i'm in it for love
i'm in it for love
here's the catch some of them are lying
and trying to win a cash prize can our
bachelor eliminate gold diggers and try
to find a true match
or will they just get played this is
love or money
well hello guys welcome to love or money
here is your beautiful bachelor you want
to go ahead and introduce yourself
what's up guys i'm bijan i'm excited to
be here and i'm very [ __ ] nervous
likewise bijon and what do you look for
in a potential match i like a bit of
confidence you know like i like that you
just spoke
i like like sweet nice energy fun
i like fun guys well i'm gonna turn
bijan around and you guys have envelopes
and markers underneath your stools you
guys can grab them and you're gonna
write whether you're in it for love or
money and just so you know once you lock
your answer in you cannot change it
look at him
handsome
good heart truly truly i like that i
don't know i'm suspect of that one you
should be i'm too much oh
do you have any expectations for today i
was recently in love with this dude and
during that time i realized oh yeah i am
ready to settle down i just haven't met
the right guy okay well hopefully you'll
find your forever love i think it's
gonna happen
well hello guys and welcome to the first
round where first impressions mean
everything bijon will have 10 minutes to
get to know you make you dance do
push-ups
take your shirt off you have free rings
i'm not going to do that to anybody
and your 10 minutes starts
now what are your names liam liam
brunell pronounce it pernell
david david nico nico and i'm ori ori
yeah how do you spell that o-h-r-y the h
is silent though well so far i like your
energy the most what yeah you haven't
said anything what about this energy a
little a little pensive maybe a little
anxious
what about you you're very quiet uh not
usually but wait so what was your name
again david david what's mine
oreo yeah
thori yeah you can call me oreo if you
want
how old are all of you how old are you
i'm 20. 20. yeah it's kind of high how
old are you
i'm like 20 actually you don't want to
say i'm not an example
what's wrong with being 28. how old are
you i'm 28. oh okay they're like i want
to change it okay all right all right um
where are you from where are you all
from i was born and raised here
i was born in bellevue washington from
orange county california i can see that
i've been here for 10 years in l.a but
chicago chicago where are you from i was
born in los angeles
but i grew up in grover beach does
anybody know what san luis obispo is
yeah i just went there last week yeah i
survived that's where i'm from wait
where did you grow up though did you
grow up in l.a i did not i did not yeah
i grew up in like a great western yeah
yeah what
what did he say i said nothing
oh yeah we'll talk a point there
no i said not a great listener because
you said you were from grover beach and
i heard it the first time oh
did you feel a connection with anyone
yet i don't know see some of them didn't
talk so that's gonna help me narrow my
choices i like a talker do you think you
know who a liar is or yeah i gotta keep
that on your mind i think the kid on the
on this or oreo or or cory ori
i think he's a freaking liar
he's like too confident chicago boy is
he's kind of cute he's got like good
energy he's like here to have fun i like
that
who is to the right
and then the guy next to or ori he seems
kind of genuine so do you know who
you're going to eliminate i do
hi guys welcome back
did you guys have fun talking to bijan
yes thank you what
two people are getting eliminated right
now all right bijan choose wisely i'm
gonna get totally in this
i'm sorry you're too quiet you guys are
definitely
are you sad you got cut so early i am i
am sad and i'm usually not a quiet
person but you said that if he's gonna
ask you to dance i would have no problem
doing that for him not for the like six
million people that are watching
i'll see you soon okay
uh-oh oh why do you think i'm trouble
why do you remember
oh this is round two where bijan will
get deeper with his potential matches
are you ready to get closer i'm ready to
get deeper
i love that intellectually
hello hi okay nico
yes oh boy coming in hot for number two
i love it yeah nice to see you nice to
see you all right so grover beach yeah
oh a good memory
hi hi ori ori yeah okay let's get to the
bottom of this tell me why you don't
trust me you're a little too confident
but you know what i i like that though i
do like that i would prefer that you're
confident and
not trust you
then trust you and you'd be boring this
is why i'm single okay we were like
talking in the green room uh-huh okay
can we guess what you do oh my god
you're probably like an influencer or
something that's also a possibility so
i'm gonna be a senior
undergrad at usc did you get in
legitimately
you look like a fake rower to me
i used to work at a bunch of the clubs
in hollywood and through there i met
this person i really want to be a
director when i'm older and so through
that person i got an interview at the dr
phil show i currently work there today
yeah i'm a double major in law history
and culture and non-governmental
organizations and social change it's a
lot i hate i hate saying my major oh
that's hot okay say it again
law history and culture and
non-governmental organizations and
social change work i was a sociology
major i just took a sociology class did
you like it it was so fun where'd you go
to school i went to george washington
university okay in dc right have you
ever seen that bridge where it's like
just like a one-way
and it's like the cars like you have to
stop on the other side to let the one
people come and then you go no a crazy
bridge change the topic
anyway i work at tao are you familiar i
love tao what do you i work there i know
doing what okay i'm a server that's cute
it's so cute do you give people your
numbers well it's a very like hetero
environment unfortunately same with my
clubs but i'm not about giving someone
my number i would absolutely do that do
it yeah you should give me your number
oh my god maybe i will okay no wait are
you not a beach person i am now i
usually go with my friends and i get a
tan oh that was quick am i out okay bye
always a pleasure
is it what
yeah everyone always thinks my name is
dijon
heyness
okay you have to go no i don't want to
leave oh my god i know let me tell you
why i'm so affectionate
i am a leo
oh sorry sorry
it might be him bye
all right dijon let's spill the tea who
do you like the best okay so i'm leaning
towards ori you like his vibe i like his
vibe he seems like he's fun
and
also serious i could marry nico and i
actually was like oh i wanted to ask you
another question
he's a nice person and do you think
they're all in it for love the young
undergrad he might be in it for money
yeah he's really performing he's young
eight years younger that's right but you
said that's hot it is kind of hot
how'd you guys like talking to bijan i
wish i had more time yeah
honestly how'd you like talking to them
i enjoyed it well that mutual liking is
going to have to stop yes one of you has
to go
transition just remember someone might
be in it for love some might be in for
money
choose wisely okay
all right so i enjoyed talking to
everybody
but
there you go
sounds good
i feel like i came on too strong what's
the one thing in both of our lives that
would connect us and i thought it would
be the bridge but he didn't know that
and i spent like two minutes on the
bridge maybe just not meant to be maybe
not yeah round three is all about
getting intimate are you ready to get
closer to these boys i'm ready all right
we'll have 10 minutes with them on this
lovely comfy couch make it worth your
while
i know did you not know there was going
to be a couch i saw it over there
surprise
this is a cat so intimate i know
how are you i'm good how are you this is
a much better setting to like better get
deeper
very deep how would you describe you
how would your peers describe oh my god
they'd call me loud funny probably like
a wild card like there's so many
different things that could happen it's
like see like what like illegal things
potentially
when was your last relationship i
actually uh got a relationship three
months ago and everything was going
perfectly i think it was a more
technical issue what does that mean
it was
both of us could get it up
but
we both
needed
[Music]
we both needed somewhere to put it
what are you into
oh
we're going into that oh no
okay probably can you go first so i know
like what's like the lines we're going i
know right um
[Music]
maybe we should just move on to the next
okay
have you ever been in love yeah
when was that
um
the last time or like just any time oh
my god you've been in love multiple
times yeah i feel like you can love
multiple people
to be honest i will not get turned on in
the bed unless i have an emotional
connection with someone i don't do one
night stand so i know that sounds like
you're lying would you ever kiss someone
on the first date of course really kiss
that was nice thank you that was nice
that was nice for you too yeah
thank you do you believe in any
conspiracy theories i don't
are you a conspiracy theorist i'm not a
conspiracy theorist i just like to
listen to them one of them
um i think buffalo might be fake i don't
think there's any buffalo in the u.s
no i think there's so much in a kiss
okay and
i agree right i feel like if you
oh
i was just getting comfortable i know
right thanks for kissing me sorry about
that no worries i liked it okay good
okay kiss
how was it tell me about it it was good
the kiss was nice okay were his lips off
he had soft lips um
nico is amazing he's yeah he's so sweet
he's really sweet he's just you know
comfortable to talk to you have to
eliminate someone in this next round
okay one might be in it for love
they both might be in it for love also
they both could be in it for money do
you know who you're going to eliminate
do you think so it has to happen it has
happened you're making me do it
hello the lucky two hello hello i am
lucky
are you guys ready
yes yeah
the moment has come
where bijan is going to decide who he
wants to go on another date with
do you know
no i don't don't do you have an idea who
you're going to pick
i like your
energy more
but i think i vibe with you a little bit
more so i think i'm going to select
you
i'll have you walk out over here
are you sad you didn't get picked i
wasn't like expecting anything so just
sort of like yeah if it happens it
happens if not now you have new friends
yeah life keeps pushing
do you think you saw past his surface
and saw his true intentions i think
and do you think you made the right
choice with whatever's in this envelope
i think you guys will see
okay all right this is love or money
and here you go oh my gosh did i present
it out to the world
before i open this
i just want to say you're the most
amazing guy
and
my decision has
intention behind it
so it's not looking good
i pick money
[Music]
but that kiss how dare you i deserve
that but let me tell you why oh actually
because you chose money i have to usher
you off right away oh my god you can't
get his number
i'm sorry you have to go this way
i knew it
dude
i'm so sad i know right you guys had
such good chemistry i really thought he
was in it for the love i don't think i
ever thought he was in it for the love
to be honest that's true the minute he
walked in you're like i have to watch
him i'm like he's true rubble i want him
[Music]
i did it and let me tell you why i did
please tell me why my sister just got
her master's degree i could take this
beautiful young man out to dinner or i
could take my sister who has literally
been taking care of me since i was two
years old
out to a dinner that she deserves for
working so hard and earning her degree
no bijon is amazing guy like i honestly
wish that it wasn't one or the other oh
you're so cute
it's okay it's okay take your sister out
i will send you guys all a picture we
might go to tao maybe he will be your
waiter oh my gosh
[Music]